d'après la légende un trésor fabuleux
serait enfermée dans le tombeau de tout
à luna est le seul moyen d'y pénétrer
c'est de réunir les trois amulettes ça
quand il ya un truc à l'intérieur c'est
sûrement ce qu'il cherchait elena doit
se rendre immédiatement au caire avec la
molette et nous on fait quoi on y va
bien sûr tout à loon premier j'ose à
peine y croire
donc qu'est ce qui se passe ou et papa
on ne sait pas où votre père
on n'est pas les seuls à chercher les
amulettes il faut découvrir qui sait
vous n'en ferez rien jeunes gens salut
les amis vous voulez pas que je vous
aide
et comment
c'est quoi ça ben il ya des tentes et
des véhicules aussi l'entrée du tombeau
de tout à l'onu je suis à la recherche
de quatre enfants et d'un chien on vous
chercher partout elles vont assurer à
l'aise c'est les meilleurs génial baby
ils vont faire quoi c'est le moment
d'agir
je suis innocent va de sortir de là
ça a été cool de partager tout ça avec
toi body